[Music]
i mean it happens to the best of us i
cannot tell you how many times i've
accidentally drop kicked a baby while
pole dancing it happens but really why
are you
filming a pole dancing video
at all but when you have like a six
month old crawling around the house
who's watching that kid apparently
nobody
and then why did you post it she was
trying to take a tick tock video of
herself pole dancing
for whatever reason
and she accidentally drop kicks her baby
in the face in the process and then
watches the video back and says oh this
is great stuff let's put it on so
everyone can see me doing it this is why
when i see these videos at least the
ones giving advice um and and i give
this woman credit she's not like she
isn't advising that we drop kick our
babies it's just that she ha that's what
she does
you know that's her own style um
but when i see the advice ones it only
solidifies my belief that you should
have to state your credentials before
giving parenting advice